I learn a very warm welcome to this
latest edition of talking Germany the
show where we do just that to my guest
today is a very familiar face here on DW
here's dirty are cops one of the leading
presenters on our main news broadcast
the journal periods durkee are cops
hello it's a pleasure it's a pleasure
for me to front a fascinating i'm really
looking forward to this now Dirk it's
not just a very passionate news
journalist and a good colleague of mine
he says someone who can tell us how
Germany sees the world and the world
sees Germany but he's also on top of
that got an impressive track record as a
sports journalist so we will have the
opportunity to talk a wee little bit
about German soccer which I'm also
looking forward to very much and one or
two other sports as first but let's say
let's begin with the serious stuff Dirk
you came you came to Berlin initially to
study economics here at the Humboldt
University yes and as you will know as a
student of economics sir one of the
questions that people who run a business
are always ask is what is the unique
selling point the USP of that business
so what is the USP of Deutsche Welle
students of business ask themselves
economics yeah the unique selling point
of Deutsche Welle yeah now we have to be
careful what we would I I'm not after
what I said cause because it's our
company here listening exactly to what
we say no at what I say now and come
comparing with CNN and BBC and so
important for example in an
international on idea maybe there is for
example I know when the war against Iraq
was or Afghanistan do you I think you
considered CNN and BBC as a broadcast
thing for one side of the war or Al
Jazeera for the other side and maybe
Deutsche Welle in this time especially
in this time was considered as a neutral
a very objective a program may be in
this time this was a unique selling
point and furthermore there could be a
specific way of
considering the world what's happening
from Germany cause looking because of
our history yeah and the development our
our values for democracy human rights
and so so therefore it might be just a
very specific view to the world that's
very interesting what you're saying and
what you're saying is often being
confirmed to me by people in the Arab
world in the people in the Middle East
that they do see a chavela as a
relatively neutral voice however it is
true that Deutsche Welle is state-funded
as a broadcaster how independent is
Deutsche Welle from the German state is
it totally independent but we are
financed by German state so we're not
that independent in an economic view but
journalistic view you think I think I
think we try we try to report a lot
about the German government may be a
little bit too much haha yeah coach
course we always report whatever
Chancellor Merkel Merkel needs we will
report it yeah and ok if you if you are
financed by the government in a way
maybe you think you have to do that but
you could do less maybe it's an
interesting point oh dear the Deutsche
Welle has chosen to prioritize four
languages German English Spanish and
Arabic and you often like idea we often
work in the same in the same space
together making news do you have the
feeling that there's a specifically
German way of sort of doing news mmm we
try to find a specific German way that
is to report to report a lot of German
topics yeah in the journal program which
I think you don't have to do in the
English programmatic way if
we tried it so we try to report a lot in
the German program about German politics
for example yeah but every happening in
any party yeah where we will if the
although it's even when it's a if it's a
small party like FTP actually is the
Liberals the junior coalition partners
here in Germany and if one ftp member is
against the other we will tell the
people in the world but maybe you'll not
do it that in the English program oh I
don't know I don't know what they'll
talk about this in just a second because
I mean there is a tendency sometimes to
get a little bit too close to German
politics because because the government
is right around the corner from where we
broadcast but we'll talk in a second
about perhaps Angela Merkel / and
perhaps why German stories have a
relevance for the international world
for our viewers out there in the world
you've had your first impressions from
Turkey are cops here's more final
preparations for the news broadcast at
2pm the studio guest has arrived the
intros have been written dear cure cops
confers with the editorial staff ironing
out the last details of the program then
it's off to the studio Dirk and a
colleague present news from all over the
world for two weeks each month
consumption are a devious felon it's
been Tina gave us our only finisher
coves guten tag on dozens of demon I
willful a dishpan on ash taiked Alice
patent office give you the lose much
target the 42 year-old also works as a
journalist and sports reporter who to
other broadcasting companies I now from
the Oakland attack for the door and
floor gets hungies to end them and I'm
toiling effort they are born Smith even
in confusing situations the versatile
journalist finds an interesting angle a
short coffee break in his kitchen at
home in constant view is a photo of his
grandfather's home city cologne we
bombed to ruins in World War two Dirk
Yakov's makes appointments for his next
shootings and his little son is waiting
to be picked up from daycare Dirk and
his partner who also works in
broadcasting have a blended family he
has three children two of them from
earlier relationships
he was born in dortmund in 1970 both
parents were teachers he studied
economics in Berlin for a while he
considered going into theatre but then
the devoted fan of Dortmund soccer club
felt the pull of television he learned
his trade alongside his colleague my pet
owner since his youth he's loved to play
basketball in his free time here too he
likes to be in the center of things and
today he's our guest on talking Germany
dear yeah cobs and erk we're going to be
talking about one or two cities that are
very important for you in your life
today we're certainly gonna be talk
about Berlin we're going to be talking
about Dortmund but I'd like to begin by
talking about cologne because you've
little photo in the kitchen yeah what's
that all about because you were talking
about German history that is a photo of
German history yes it is it's so let me
first say cologne is a city I like very
much they're friends of mine I like the
mentality there I often be there and
enjoy it there so but it's a little bit
of ugly town and I guess city cause of
the people the reason is the reason that
the reason is what you see on the photo
the distress distraction it was totally
destroyed in ruins like many other
cities in Germany after World War Two
and as I think there's a very impressive
photo fascinating you see how the Empire
of the thousand years ended Nazi Reich
yeah whereas the church of the thousand
years was it was made it remained yeah
and I often have to think about it what
happened in our history in our German
history they're just 45 it's so 70 years
ago ago and the whole country was in in
ruins it's mm-hmm it's very encouraged
to be reminded of that every do you have
a connection to
to the city that's more direct than the
fact that you visited there a lot that
you have friends there I think you've
got you you had a family connection yeah
my gram I my grandfather is from Cologne
and it he experienced that destruction
your grandfather yeah ya know what did
he tell me they had all my grand father
in Dortmund also yeah my grandmother and
also the the houses were bombed mhm so
and they had to build new houses after
the word one let's make a fresh start
okay you've mentioned it Dortmund yeah
the the city that I think is closest to
your heart it's in what Germans call
where was born it's where you were born
and so I think it's where your heart
beats in many ways it's in that it's in
the raga beat what the Germans called
the rug beat the raw valley the one of
Germany's industrial heartlands just
give us a feeling for the raga be what
does what he'd like you say it's an
industrial area but the time is over
that's what it was in the last century
it was the industrial it was it was
industrial heart of Germany so 10 11 12
cities very close together and in each
city you have companies for coal and
steel production and big names like to
sing and group and what have you hush
hush indoor monkey exactly and the time
is over now that ended the production
was the mining was became too expensive
in the worldwide market and the rural
area had to change and it was a some
cities managed some cities happened so
far managed and Dortmund is a city has
managed structural change structural
development there are some new
industries upset place their micro
techniques banks and insurances and and
so on so Dalton has managed
change nowadays you won't find any more
industrial disease they are ok you left
the Dortmund to come to Berlin as we've
already mentioned a burn you began
studying economics but that you you
moved off into journalism how did that
happen a chance a little bit because I
started like like every student I looked
for a job to work and I found this at EF
German program big channel here in GM a
channel very influential you know
because the studios were close to my
former flat and I asked there I can work
and I worked there and then I had had a
big lock to be came to the possibility
to work in a journalistic way new try
and to learn and they let me do they
have first pieces my first report and in
the same time I continued my studying in
economics and when it came to the end to
my diploma as you say here I had already
so many experiences in the TV business
and as a report and as a journalist and
serve and as an editor that I decided to
continue this as my job and now you are
now you are a news anchor DW you work
outside DW as well and I once come back
to that point that you were you were
quite critical of how Deutsche Welle
gets sort of quite close to German
stories but just I think that German
stories can be very important for
viewers outside Germany I think that's
true is it not and because of our
specific solutions we find here in
Germany for some for some problems
that's interesting that you use that
very word because I offset I after when
I'm talking to people from outside
German our very you know I say to them
you know people who come to Germany from
you know countries at the moment there's
lots of people coming from Spain and
Portugal not just for economic reasons
but people are fascinated by Germany and
the people very often say to me Germany
is a country that solves problems it has
solutions for today's problems per inch
think and more than other countries for
example you say or bread Britain's other
interests yeah it might be so of you
think the Germans try to solve problems
okay in your career in journalism would
have been their stories that have been
closest to your heart the most important
stories that you have covered in the
very beginning it was 911 I started as a
presenter and my second day it happened
in New York and Washington the terrorist
attacks that was right at the beginning
that must riding huge impression on you
because that were yeah so I started
never did it before to work as a
presenter and my third day it was 911
and it was not only work day but to
force a the story broke what were you
thinking you must be very nervous it was
like in a tunnel yeah I had I had to do
my work now I want to manage this I want
to I want to succeed in this in this
this job and that I that's what I tried
and and I manage this but but three day
three weeks four weeks after 911 I
failed just distressed it caught up with
you yeah quite electrolyte and I need a
break I needed a break for some days I
can alyssa relax absolutely yeah yeah
but poison most impressive on the earth
and furthermore two or three years ago
when there were the german anniversaries
of when the war came down and the
reunification yeah what we had a very
big program concerning this and I that
well it was a very nice time where you
could talk about your own history in
German we're coming back to German
history again we're going to talk a
little bit about sort of Germany east
and west because in the last two decades
or more huge amounts of money have been
invested in the regions that used to be
East Germany to help them catch up with
what has in many ways been the more
prosperous west but the feeling is that
there's still a long way to go so
Germans pay a monthly solidarity
surcharges it's called for investment
cindy east amounting to 5.5 percent of
their monthly pay packet but it is
increasingly controversial because there
are places in the West like dirk's
hometown of Dortmund that are also these
days struggling the city of dog Mont
would have had to shut down the
municipal indoor pool in the OP Lebec
district but the local swimming
association has taken on responsibility
for the pool mostly on a volunteer basis
then veered us if we hadn't stepped in
and no one else did then this pool would
have been shut down in 2004 like and
that would have been a mild disaster for
the athletic district up a big under
Glinda kept us close to the wall
swimming pools or road maintenance dot
bunt is deep in debt but each year 30
million euros in solidarity payments to
eastern Germany are siphoned from door
Pont taxpayers this is it was I can't
make this plausible to our citizens for
all our understanding for and solidarity
with eastern Germany people feel this
system is perverse we think age should
be based on need not compass direction
with lethal today things in many Eastern
German cities look a lot better than
here in the war valley the equation look
at what possibilities the cities have
and decide on that basis who should
receive and who should pay solidarity
surcharges yeah son was in a discussion
is long overdue because the hard times
are over in the East and when things
have gotten so hard here in the river
valley we should look at how the money
can be better distributed episode
don't want has funded a new art center
despite its financial difficulties the
mayor defends the expense of prestige
object as an investment in the future of
Ghana that is a zoo on the other hand we
have to see to it that in the quality of
life competition between cities we offer
an infrastructure that attracts
companies that create jobs uniform
fatigue hour and at our social
infrastructure functions just use
italian first book to a function yet and
augment isn't the only city in the Ruhr
Valley plagued by crumbling
infrastructure and a lack of funds Tokyo
Cubs you like me you pay the solar of
the Solidarity surcharge on a
month-by-month basis e are you happy to
do so happy to pay well that's it
realistic answer in itself yeah but I I
accept that yeah I think it's necessary
it has been necessary no until now and I
think it is still necessary cause the
eastern part of germany was very down in
1989 and cities couldn't have survived
without it okay it's interesting that
you say you know am I happy to be paying
this what it's an additional tax yeah
and and I you know the figure is very
interesting that it's very difficult to
measure how much money has been paid
from west to east in the last two
decades or so but the figure that is
most often quoted by the German media at
the moment is somewhere around 1.4
trillion euros have been paid to the
east yeah the amazing thing is I mean
you're shaking your head but you can't
imagine that you carry city for people
outside Germany it's an incredible
figure the amazing thing is certainly
for people from babalu the whole state
yeah exactly yeah yeah yeah true but for
people from the anglo-saxon world that
has been in an additional tax not all of
it has come from this solidarity so
judge there's never been any protests
about that or anything people have just
paid and paid and paid yeah very German
very nice to German something
in the report that we just had yeah we
had already 0 the the Social Democrat
mayor of Dortmund say you can just you
can't explain anymore why the poor
cities in the raw area have to go into
high levels of debt in order to pay
their share of the Solidarity packed
what do people you know in door and say
about it now because we do we saw in the
report that you know there's there's
hardship in dortmund yeah but they're
paying lots of money elsewhere it's very
very difficult to compare the situation
of eastern Germany after four decades of
socialism and the rural area mmm who had
great times in the industrial a time
yeah but when the time is over now it's
not a situation they have to change by
themselves I think like I described
already littleton has managed and can't
accept that i would say to the people
are people in Dortmund angry at the
moment or are people getting angry not
as far as i know i am also very german
that they say i mean people are living
facing this kind of hardship and those
in the staying calm there's a lot of
unemployment in Dortmund yeah observable
yeah of course no I'm not happy hmm but
I i I've never heard this that's people
of Dortmund said to me or this
solidarity surcharge stop it okay we
need you mentioned there was very
interesting you were talking about how
after german reunification after the
wall came down obviously the former east
germany had been through long difficult
communist times in the was was
devastated economically yeah do you you
live in berlin yeah berlin is surrounded
by what was an Eastern German state
Brandenburg yeah do you go out into
Brandenburg a lot you do you look for
landscape beautiful landscape and
because I'm very interested what is your
impression when you're out in
Brandenburg is this is this is one of
the states where all this money has been
spent do you have the feeling that
Brandenburg is now catching up has
caught up will cat
chap what's the situation many people
say Brandenburg is going going down on
her there are the cities like Potsdam or
corpus I think yeah in these cities you
see the money they received the the
houses are rebuilt besides our new
streets are in a good condition this is
my impression as well just my problem
what on the countryside there are also
many people who leave the very small
villages go to Berlin or the cities like
pots them and so that's the problem of
Brandenburg yeah but maybe not only from
Brandenburg of brant Berg that people
leave the small villages and so the
countryside is going to die ok so maybe
certainly the Solidarity surcharge needs
to continue for some time to come from
the anecdotal evidence that you're
giving me here yeah that's quite
interesting tell me about it just lets
go back to Dortmund you were giving me
the impression that you know dopeman now
is facing vary from the report as well
facing serious problems does Dortmund
have a future yes yes as it has already
shown so there are new industries that
have taken place there what kind of
industries we talk about here Logistics
is insurances micro technics around the
university yeah and lots of new places
to work hmm have been founded and
developed and yes dalton has a future
okay if you are talking about Dortmund
future and you're talking about
something of a renaissance something of
a research there how important is
Borussia Dortmund football club you know
Chris it's the heart of all it's the
heart of it so I can see your eyes
lighting up yeah a lot nadama wouldn't
be the same without borsa Dortmund yeah
so that's you can say it's the cultural
identity people say there's a very close
link between the club the ethos of the
club and the ethos of the city yes tell
me about that because the
the main attraction that's the point
borussia dortmund is the main attraction
of Dortmund you don't have a unique
selling point you don't have a river
like the Rhine and click on you don't
have a nice castle or a big church or
whatever yeah you only have this
Football Club they have the successful
football club and so its usual
endorsement to wear the yellow black
dresses like we wear our suits and
that's it
it's interesting I I had to do a little
bit of reading up on all this because it
did the vocabulary is very interesting
in Germany the the English language word
patchwork family is used and I was
trying to work out how common that is in
the English language in the in the US
yeah people are telling me yes patchwork
family is used reversing it patchwork
family or you know people are still
trying to get used to the idea you know
they don't quite have a word for it in
the UK people are using the word a
blended family that's used in the US as
well it's quite interesting that really
the vocabulary doesn't exist quite yet
yeah but things we have seen you will
you will find in England or USA as well
or absolutely of course yeah but it's
interesting because I did discover that
the word patchwork family was introduced
into the into the German language by a
translator it was translating a book
from the English language about
patchwork families and she used the word
patrick family ok yeah that's the
vocabulary that's the vocabulary let's
talk about the reality tell us about
your patchwork family first of all is
much easier than the case we've seen in
the coach just have my elder son who is
15 years old now and he's half the time
with his mother yeah and with me so one
week with her one wing with me we
separated when he was five years old and
since since then we have doing this like
like this and I've been doing this like
this and so was easy stuff it was there
a while you were a single parent yes ok
single Marva which is quite unusual I
mean most single parents are mothers yes
well yeah when he was five and six and
seven years old it was yeah the one
there were not so many fathers like me
yeah um alone with her son or for a week
of it yeah and now I'm with my new wife
or we have a very little son 17 month
old and expecting the next one and now
it's it's like it now it's a usual
family situation with my older son ok
United it's interesting that you are
talking about this as though it is the
most normal thing in the world
in some parts of the world it i'm sure
it is very not more like berlin in some
parts of the world it's not so normal
yeah in the report I got the feeling
that it's a you know it's a big
adventure and things fit into place and
yeah is that the reality it's very
difficult you know you must you you have
to agree with all the parents who are
involved in the situations and that is
not so easy and furthermore know if I've
lost my thought ok but so when you say
it's not so easy yeah i mean the the the
guy in the report he said you know you
know we get on with it yeah when you are
faced with these problems and organized
you have to organize so many things to
manage a patchwork family with five
children yeah and it's very difficult i
think so it's not the thing you choose i
would i would say if you have to choose
you you you'll be lucky with your
partner for the rest of your life yeah
and patchwork is a patchwork is a
difficult thing to organize and yeah but
if you can work but the situation is we
want to be lucky with our partners and
we have high
hi intentions so we have to make it work
and we separate and that's the price yep
and hey I was saying you know I was
asking hell normal normal it is in a
city like Berlin yeah do you know how do
people react to somebody who's in a
patchwork family did they just say well
that's life these days all in the big
cities it became now almost normal yeah
I did actually find I don't know who's
actually seen this figure host parents
so my elder son in the class his his
classmates it automates the most of them
have separated parents yeah them now I
know the story I mean from my kids going
through schools here in Berlin it's I
actually found a figure of how many
families with kids under 18 are viewed
as blended families or patchwork
families in Germany and it's 13.6 of
households so nearly 15-percent across
Germany yeah so it's the modern world
well while we're talking about kids in
Germany do yeah very often people say to
me Germany is not a child friendly
country what's your experience could be
better and it's not so it could be
better it's still in the job I think not
difficult to organize the time also that
there's still enough time for the child
for the children and then for even if
both parents or want to work yeah we saw
you as a little kid growing up in
dormont there yeah do your children are
your children growing up in a completely
different way from the way you grew up I
certainly know for me my kids that their
lives these days are super organized
there's there's lots of hobbies there's
lots of expectations and all all this
yeah hmm not much time for play dancers
it depends on you it depends on you if
you if you tell you if you tell your son
you have to learn an instrument like
sports and so on and so on and care for
your school and your
work you have to give him the spare time
of course absolutely yeah so we decided
one instrument one sports club that's
enough good okay that's that's cool I
spent ninety-five percent of my
childhood playing football down you know
at the back of the house yeah but I
didn't become a very good football
player and you are a journalist you're a
sports journalist you're a basketball
player you are also a right you also
write lyrics I know you write songs you
know not just alerts you what you try to
and the genre that you write in is the
German schlager please give me a quick
definition of what a German schlager
song is I think that people could
discuss ters and there is no exact
definition everything's so I would say
it's a song in German German language ok
so it has to be in German has to be
written in German German language and it
should be a little bit successful and
hit mm-hmm Jack you say word Slugger
actually means hit yeah that's a German
but it can in invite it might be in the
80s might be rock music and 30 years
later and so German rock music I like a
backward admirer who is and I think
nowhere in the world popular and 30
years later it's saga
I've got an idea now ash lager song is
like the kind of music you can watch it
the Eurovision Song Contest that's
pretty close to what it is yeah for
example ok Duke so I schlongs should
think german and they sing english
they're no good but they sing other
languages as well it's interesting
because I actually I discovered that the
the word for a schlager song in the
Netherlands the Dutch word yeah is a
lievens lead the earthly a song about
life quite literally you know a real one
that's it ah we're getting closer we're
getting close butch lager is about life
and I'm sure you can find the whole
wisdom of life within 10 or 12 sloggers
yeah ok it's interesting because
sometimes when I'm trying to explain to
people who are non-germans what ash
lager is I say it's a little bit like
country and western music for example
it's got the kind of wisdom that country
western where did we say you know
language I mentioned the Dutch flogger
tradition I mean a band like I'm trying
to think of an international band who
would be sort of a slug a band that
people will say oh yeah I know what you
mean abba-abba-abba uber is good Shalaka
slugger ah good luck I bet it smells
good lager and batch lager you know you
and your slugger Yosh lager songs what
are they about the title is the others
are guilty always and that's why we can
be happy because if there is a problem
always the others are guilty there you
are the wisdom of life the wisdom of
life in its lager song yet do you have a
schlager collection at home do you have
lots of Slugger records wish yeah and
you listen to it when you're cooking
dinner next to that no no no no no I
like that not like that's not like that
mother also be talking also Beethoven
yeah um you wrote your schlag a song for
the Cologne carnival yeah we're just a
little bit like the carnival anywhere
else in the world in Brazil aware ever
it's very popular heroes because the
kelowna there's a chasm special speech
special kind of special island I local
it's just a kind of dialect of german
dialect and
i love it i can speak it and that's why
okay let's just get a shot very quick
review but when people go to the
carnival they tend to dress up dirk is
no exception let's just have a look at
we got it yeah yeah there we go it's I
mean carnival you have to trust him most
people's although not so difficult cause
I didn't have to do too much with my
hair just need this this costume not
that I'm part of the costume if I I
brought did you get your eyebrows done
yeah a little bit painted yes I go and
then of course you need a Spock needs a
phaser if you are at the top and ya you
were gonna forward and press the other
people in the pub let me ever go let me
go yeah so this is your original Spock
style phaser yeah you know Captain Kirk
Captain Kirk had a fight phaser as well
Kirk yes of course but his was like a
bit longer wasn't it no no I think it's
on same sort of thing it's not the
original one it's not the original one
and it's it you've taped it up a little
bit here because it's been is it's been
to the carnival and back ora por dia
okay we're gonna move on very quick
think I need a new one talking Germany
quiz time yeah okay quick questions
quick answers Dortmund or Berlin um
which is home doggoned he's got up with
us already the music I can hear in the
background right I'm gonna ask you one
question do you prefer reading good news
or bad news good news good for you me
too that is all we've got time for this
time round on talking Germany our guest
today our very own dick yeah Cubs a man
of many facets been interesting talking
to if you've enjoyed this company as
much as I have them do come back next
week do by the way also check out my
talking Germany blog are on our internet
site where you can also catch up on any
shows the miter base for now herb bye
bye and just
you